[Applause]
hi I just enjoy the modesty and Reserve
that you have when greeted with that
much love and excitement just a kind of
a an English oh my God not me it is a
little bit of oh my God although uh I
have a CD of that sort of Applause at
home uh yeah yeah which I play to myself
every now and then coing down when you
perform minor tasks around the house and
then you just
yay yeah yeah you know I can't believe I
was think about this today I was house
still feels like a relatively new show
to me not to me no well you but no that
was that was that was eight years it is
eight years that's unbelievable it is
actually long enough for me to have
become a uh a a nephrologist uh a board
certified nephologist I I mean I could
have become the real thing and here I am
still eight years later Faking
It uh it's really a shocking waste of
human energy yes you could have gone you
could have gone to a great Medical
School you be helping people right now I
could I could be alleviating suffering
yes instead of pulling faces and
shouting um you're making people happy
that's important well I I would like to
think so yes thank you for suggesting
that until I said it I don't think
anyone believed it but uh that's the
power I have in this medium uh eight
years and I don't think people
appreciate I've been I was actually on
your set for a little bit once the hard
work that goes into doing uh a show like
yours uh a single camera show that your
call time must be very on the early in
the morning you work late at night how
do you vent how do what do you do to
relax
um I uh well I I have a number of
outlets mhm but I'll only tell you two
of them okay um these are the legal ones
these are the legal Outlets yes I well
the the um music is a great uh Solace to
me mhm you're a very good musician thank
you for saying that my other great lover
is is is boxing and and that was really
designed you may as well call it venting
actually it's professional venting you
actually box
well no I don't I mean I'm hopeless I'm
absolutely hopeless but I've been doing
it for a long time who do you box who do
you fight uh small
children uh can I get in on this this
sounds fun and I don't think I'll be
hurt it's terrific so you you you box
and you box with I'm guessing a sparring
partner and you and it's exhausting I
have done a little bit of boxing and I'm
more of a slapper I right slap and
shriek which is my technique which is I
think is going to be in the next
Olympics yes it's going to be slapping
that is going to be and I going to get
nine medals for this uh it is absolutely
shattering and one of the things I love
about it is that when you do you do any
job for a long period of time time seems
to accelerate and you suddenly go my God
I can't believe six months have gone by
since you know right everything gets
faster but when you get into a boxing
ring 3 minutes is an it
eternity um time really stops your
you're you're uh and to to reverse that
if we could live life as intensely as as
people do inside a boxing ring it we'd
be living for 10,000 years not a very
pleasant 10,000 Years we' be yeah but uh
we'd be bloodied and crying constantly
maybe it's a terrible idea it's a
terrible but it would be intense yeah
intensity to life yeah